T
COLD, THE DEMOCRATS SAID SORRY,
THERE WAS A GLITCH, MY BAD.
LET'S BRING IN TEXAS
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT, DO YOU
BELIEVE GOVERNOR THAT THIS IS A
HUMAN TRAFFICKING RING THAT
JOE BIDEN'S ADMINISTRATION IS
PARTICIPATING IN?
>> SO IT REALLY IS, ALL YOU HAVE
TO DO IS LOOK AT THE NUMBERS OF
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER AS WELL AS THOSE WHO
ARE VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND YOU SEE THAT THERE IS ONE
PERSON WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THIS AND THAT'S JOE BIDEN.
GO BACK TO AND A HALF YEARS AGO
AND HE SAW THE FEWEST ILLEGAL
BORDER CROSSINGS AND MULTIPLE
DECADES, AND THEN JOE BIDEN
ELIMINATED EVERY MEASURE PUT IN
PLACE BY PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT
HAS NOW LED TO AN ALL-TIME
RECORD IN THE PAST YEAR THERE BE
MORE THAN 2.2 MILLION PEOPLE
CROSSING THE BORDER ILLEGALLY.
MANY OF THOSE ARE VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
MANY DID NOT MAKE IT HERE
BECAUSE THEY LOST THEIR LIFE ON
THE WAY.
THAT'S WHY THE UNITED NATIONS
DECLARED THE BORDER BETWEEN THE
UNITED STATES AND MEXICO BIDEN'S
BORDER IS THE MOST DANGEROUS
CROSSING AND THE ENTIRE WORLD.
AND SO WHAT BIDEN IS DOING BY
TURNING A BLIND EYE TO THIS IS
OUTRAGEOUS AND IT IS THE BIGGEST
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS CAUSED BY
JOE BIDEN.
>> Jesse: DO YOU WONDER WHY
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT JUST CAN'T
BREAK INTO THESE OVERSEAS BANK
ACCOUNTS AND JUST SEES THESE
ELICIT TO ASSETS THAT THE
CARTELS ARE PILING UP?
DO YOU THINK IT MAY HAVE
SOMETHING TO DEAL WITH MAYBE
SOME OF THESE RICH AND WEALTHY
AND POWERFUL PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES ARE USING THE SAME
BANKS?
>> SO, JESSE, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION COULD DO THAT IF
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DID
WHAT I DID JUST A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AGO.
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO I DECLARED
THE CARTELS TERRORIST
ORGANIZATIONS, IF THE PRESIDENT
WOULD DO THAT, IT TRIGGERS A
FEDERAL LAW THAT WOULD ALLOW HIM
TO GO INTO THOSE BANK ACCOUNTS
AND GET THOSE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT THE CARTELS ARE
MAKING OFF OF THIS.
>> Jesse: IF WE CAN SEIZE
MONEY FROM ISIS BANK ACCOUNTS,
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO SEE HIS
CARTEL BANK ACCOUNTS, THAT'S A
HUGE ISSUE IN A GREAT IDEA THAT
YOU HAD.
I WAS GOING TO SAY I'M SURPRISED
THAT JOE BIDEN DOES NOT HAVE
THAT IDEA, BUT ACTUALLY,